check this out so this is a
representative Harriet Hageman who I
like a lot she started asking secretary
Halen about energy poverty and and
basically should people starve in the
name of green energy Madam Secretary do
you believe energy poverty is a good
thing
I don't know the term ma'am you've never
heard of the phrase energy poverty
I have not heard of that term but I it's
probably pretty self-explanatory though
don't you think well I think what we're
really trying to do with our clean
energy goals is make energy more
affordable for okay single American so
I'd like you to answer my question which
is do you believe energy poverty is a
good thing in other words the people
going into poverty or being unable to
afford food or medicine or things like
that because of the rising cost of
energy do you think that's a good thing
congresswoman I understand the
challenges that many Americans face I
raise my child as a single mom and had
to decide whether I could pay the rent
or my student loans so you a gas bill so
I understand that it's very difficult
yes so you agree that energy poverty is
not a good thing is that right
um I I want to say that we are working
very hard to make energy more efficient
and more affordable which is why we're
moving forward on our clean energy but
that is the case coal is an affordable
energy isn't it it has been for decades
I I know that our country uh relied on
coal for a very long time and we're very
grateful for so many of the workforce
that powered our nation for right and
coal is an affordable energy isn't it
ma'am I I want to say that
um President Biden believes in energy
Independence for our country and I
believe that using uh different energy
sources around the country will help
communities everywhere and including
keep energy more affordable including
coal and oil and gas correct
uh congresswoman we are in a transition
currently to a clean energy future and I
believe very strongly that we will get
there and energy will be more affordable
so then energy poverty is a policy of
this Administration from what I can tell
from your answers congresswoman we are
working very hard to make sure that all
Americans can
um
access affordable energy and that's one
of the reasons why we are working hard
but your policies do the exact opposite
which increase the cost of energy
correct uh congresswoman uh President
Biden truly understands the challenge of
working people and we want to make sure
that energy can be affordable for every
American she's a single mother so
clearly she knows Libby
I I honestly don't think they care I I
honestly don't think they care I think
in the Quest for their Green New Deal or
whatever it is they would gladly starve
half the world I really believe that
yeah and I think that's pretty clear
when you look at the numbers and when
you look at the gains
um economically that fossil fuel has
made throughout the world and when you
consider the expense that goes into you
know the electric cars and all of these
other kinds of energy systems they're
not affordable for a lot of people if
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell